bah écoute et l'ambiance au sein du qg
s'est calmé et les soutiens et bien se
sont déplacés à quelques rues d'ici
place arago pour et bien a commencé à
célébrer cette victoire de louis aliot à
perpignan je suis avec jérôme rivière
eurodéputés du rassemblement national
président de la délégation française au
parlement européen du groupe identité
démocratie
racontez-moi un peu ce votre réaction au
sujet de cette victoire de louis aliot à
perpignan et que vous êtes d'abord je
suis extrêmement reconnaissant aux
habitants de perpignan par pina mais
d'avoir permis cette victoire d'abord
parce que c'est une belle victoire pour
leur ville ont écrit une page d'histoire
ils ont libéré perpignan d'une
municipalité qui ne fonctionnait pas
mais surtout ils ont démontré qu'ils
étaient capables de retrouver leur
liberté la liberté de voter contre
l'escroquerie du front républicain
pendant longtemps nous a expliqué qu'il
fallait marginaliser les
les élus et les électeurs du
rassemblement national et le travail
formidable de louis a été de permettre
cette victoire large victoire 53 % qui
éclaire le chemin pour demain les
élections départementales les élections
régionales et surtout l'élection
présidentielle de 2022 n'auront plus ce
mur cette escroquerie morale politique
d'un front républicain
nous pouvons gagner sur nos idées dans
un combat face à face un combat qui n'a
pas toujours été loyal parce que le
maire sortant n'était pas un adversaire
loyal louis l'a remporté et je m'en
félicite et je remercie encore une fois
les perpignanais petites escroqueries au
sujet de ce front républicain qui a été
mise en place par les marcheurs et les
écologistes ici à perpignan escroquerie
c'est un terme qui a aussi repris louis
aliot tout à l'heure c'est pas un peu
fort quand même comme terme non parce
qu'il s'agit effectivement d'une
escroquerie morale et politique
il vous avez des listes qui se
combattent les unes contre les autres
vous avez ici un candidat en marche qui
ce combat qui combattait monsieur pujol
avec des mots terribles des mots bien
pire que ce qu'a pu employer le noyau
qui au lendemain du premier tour dira
mais finalement non
je vais appeler à voter pour le maire
donc c'est se moquer des électeurs on ne
peut pas expliquer que quelqu'un que qui
a été critiquée avec des mots terribles
avec des points et des sujets précis
peut demain être une solution aux
principes que nous ne serions pas
républicain ce n'est pas vrai les élus
et les électeurs du rassemblement
national et des listes soutenues par
leurs ensembles nationaux sont des
françaises et des français qui sont tjrs
aiment leur pays qu'ils aiment les
projets qu'on leur présente et qui
veulent simplement manifesté par leur
vote leur liberté de choisir en
démocratie le chemin qu'il souhaite
tracer
et donc cette escroquerie c'était tenté
de faire croire qu'il n'y avait pas de
choix et qu'il y avait une sorte
d'obligation à soutenir un candidat
quelle que soit sa nature politique
contre le candidat du rassemblement
national
aujourd'hui c'est fini ça ne marche plus
et ça ne marchera plus louis aliot aura
la lourde tâche de faire mieux ici à
perpignan cette élection de louis aliot
à perpignan elle va elle va servir
d'exemple pour le rassemblement national
pour les années à suivre ça peut
déterminer beaucoup de choses à l'avenir
c'est effectivement très important dans
la mesure où nous devons démontrer ce
qu'on fait d'ailleurs les maires
sortants vous savez que ce soit fréjus
ou hénin beaumont nous avions des mères
la dernière fois qu'ils avaient trop ont
triomphé lors des élections municipales
ils ont été réélu dès le premier tour au
mois de mai au mois de mars
donc c'est bien la preuve que les villes
que nous emportons sont bien gérées et
que les électeurs adhère donc je suis
certain que louis sera faire la même
chose
c'est une taxe plus l'eau parce que
perpignan est une très grande ville
inséré au milieu d'une dune d'une
agglomération importante les par
ailleurs louis et quelque part le
symbole de ce localisme que nous
défendons vous savez nous souhaitons
mettre un terme à cette mondialisation
effrénée qui nous a emmenés dans cette
dans cette crise du coc vide il faut
bien le dire où nous avons découvert à
cette occasion qu' un certain nombre de
nos industries et est de délocaliser que
l'absence de frontières nous mettez en
grande difficulté par la présence d'un
élu fortement enracinée symbolique dans
une grande ville nous mettrons en
pratique tout c'est toutes ces
politiques que nous souhaitons appliquer
sur le plan national
donc oui c'est une force de symbole très
fort et louis aliot est un personnage
central au sein du rassemblement
national elle son élection conforte ce
ce localisme que nous voulons présenter
et qui sera la réponse sérieuse aux
projets d'europe écologie les verts dont
on entend parler aujourd'hui messieurs
sont des mondialistes forcené qui
préfèrent continuer dans le modèle
d'ultralibéralisme que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui ou qui nous propose plutôt
une sorte de décroissance dont on ne
veut pas la réalité c'est un projet
ancré dans les territoires et et louis
en est un très beau symbole c'est quoi
la patte du rassemblement national au
niveau local à quoi va ressembler la
politique municipale de louis aliot
quelle marge de manoeuvre vous avez à ce
niveau-là et goûté à l'or sur le dossier
même des dossiers de perpignan je suis
pas de perpignan donc je ne connais pas
les dossiers mais ce que je sais que lou
il fera d'abord c'est qu'il aura à coeur
de servir les intérêts de tous les
perpignanais et non pas ceux d'un clan
ce qui a marqué la même amende
la mandature précédente et la
municipalité précédente c'est qu'il y
avait vraiment le sentiment de prendre
les citoyens pour des consommateurs
politique c'est à dire que en fonction
des communautés
il leur donnait tel petit avantage c'est
le petit subventions pour essayer
d'acheter les électeurs
c'est un système qui est qui et qui
absolument révoltant et qui d'ailleurs a
montré ses limites parce que les
électeurs ne veulent pas être traités
comme des clients soient traités comme
des citoyens et la louis l'a dit tout à
l'heure dans son dans son dans son
intervention il souhaite traiter
l'ensemble des perpignanais comme des
citoyens et c'est le plus important
merci beaucoup jérôme rivière d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes eurodéputés du rassemblement
national et président du groupe identité
et démocratie au parlement européenne
donc vous l'avez entendu jérôme rivière
qui croit beaucoup en la politique de de
louis aliot à perpignan